Am Anfang war das Pferd.
Pferde aus Goldstaub oder ein Elefant,
der Kunststücke macht.
Alles ohne den Einsatz lebender Tiere.
Das deutsche
Traditionsunternehmen Roncalli
führt mit Hologrammen
den Zirkus in ein neues Zeitalter.
Für Direktor Bernhard Paul
ist Wandel ein Teil des Geschäfts.
Es gibt halt nicht mehr grüne Wiesen,
wo man mit dem Zirkus gastiert,
sondern man gastiert auf irgendeinem
Innenstadtparkplatz oder so etwas.
Also, die Lebensumstände für Tiere
haben sich geändert.
Deswegen muss man auch
dem Rechnung tragen.
Man muss die Welt beobachten
und auch die Veränderungen
und die Kurskorrekturen
vollziehen immer wieder.
Zu Beginn der Show
sind Hologramme die Stars der Manege.
Herzlich willkommen im Zirkus Roncalli.
Dann geht es real weiter.
Manege frei!
Das Spiel beginnt!
In Lübeck ist der Zirkus mit dem Programm
„Storyteller – Gestern, Heute, Morgen“
zu Gast.
Das Konzept: die romantische Welt des
Zirkus ins 21. Jahrhundert zu transportieren.
Für die Zukunft steht neben
den Hologrammen ein Artist,
der mit einem Industrieroboter interagiert.
Zirkus muss überraschen.
Man darf nicht da sitzen und sagen:
„Ich weiß genau, was jetzt kommt.“
Man muss sagen: „Was ist das?
Das hab ich noch nie gesehen!“
Dampfmaschine, Auto,
elektrisches Licht und so weiter –
das wurde im Zirkus als Erstes gebracht
als Sensation,
und wir bringen jetzt
die Holographie in den Zirkus.
Markus Strobl kontrolliert vor jeder Show
die Technik und die Projektionsfläche:
Elf computergesteuerte Laserbeamer
projizieren Bilder
auf ein hauchdünnes metallisches Netz.
Die Investition in die Zukunft ließ sich
der Zirkus rund 500.000 Euro kosten.
Hier haben wir schon
einen Schaden bereinigt.
Und da haben wir eine Schneiderin,
die näht dann einen Nylonfaden.
Aber das ist wirklich natürlich für Kinder – die
sitzen in der ersten Reihe und denken sich:
„Boah, ich möchte mal da hinfassen.“
Eine auf Extended Reality – also erweiterte
Realität – spezialisierte Firma im Ruhrgebiet
war für die Umsetzung verantwortlich.
Idee und Konzept stammen von Roncalli.
Zunächst wurden am Computer
3D-Animationen der Figuren modelliert.
Auch das Zirkuszelt hat das Team
um Birger Wunderlich virtuell nachgebaut.
So konnte der Blickwinkel der Betrachter
zur Projektionsfläche
und den Animationen errechnet werden.
Tatsächlich ist so ein Elefant von der
Oberflächenstruktur
auch sehr, sehr aufwendig.
Das heißt, natürlich haben wir Elefantenfotos,
die dort als Textur draufliegen.
Aber so ein Elefant hat auch Härchen, das
heißt, wenn man nachher diesen Elefanten
mal in der Manege sich anschaut,
der hat über 40.000 Härchen –
das zu modellieren
oder beziehungsweise zu rendern,
das macht das Ganze schon spannend.
Im 300 Quadratmeter großen Studio wurden
die Hologramme getestet.
Hier kann ein Viertel ihrer Originalgröße
abgerufen werden.
Nicht alle Figuren sind Teil
der aktuellen Show.
Also, Interaktion macht das Ganze natürlich
viel, viel spannender in Zukunft.
Das heißt, die Artisten können direkt mit
den holografischen Elementen interagieren.
Sie können wie ein Künstler mit
den Elementen neue Arrangements gestalten,
Welten zusammenstellen und sich dann
durch diese Welten bewegen.
Für die aktuelle Tournee
wurde Zirkusdirektor Bernhard Paul
vor grünem Hintergrund gefilmt und
dann in einen virtuellen Ballon animiert.
Doch fehlt den Zuschauern bei den
Hologrammen nicht das Zirkusgefühl,
der Reiz des Spontanen? Oder ist tierfrei
einfach zeitgemäß?
Ich find’s gut, dass Tiere weggelassen sind
[werden], weil es ist nicht artgerecht.
Und ich find’s eigentlich gut, wenn man
Tiere live sehen möchte, sollte man gucken,
dass man in einen Tierpark geht.
Das war so atemberaubend irgendwie,
dass das auch so losging,
also, das hat mir echt gut gefallen. Das Ganze
hab ich noch nie vorher so gesehen.
Mir fehlt die klassische Roncalli-Romantik,
wie ich sie bisher erlebt habe,
und das Hologramm und die Technik ist [sind]
es eben nicht.
Es hat irgendwie der Pferdegeruch gefehlt ein
bisschen … bei den Pferden,
aber ich fand’s eigentlich ganz gut.
Es ist toll gemacht, muss ich wirklich sagen.
Bei dem Elefanten hat man das Gefühl, er
sitzt einem gleich auf dem Schoß –
so realistisch,
so toll kommt das rüber.
Bei der nächsten Tournee sollen die virtuelle
und die reale Welt
noch mehr miteinander verschmelzen.
Eines steht fest:
Der Zirkus bleibt auch in Zukunft eine
magische Welt voller Überraschungen.